weeks ago I was researching Google's
work with military drones when I noticed
something really weird in the footage
take a look this Air Force officer is
flying a 60 million dollar drone using
an Xbox controller this got me thinking
this country has always relied on having
access to the best Technologies American
tech companies have largely turned their
backs on the US military thousands of
Google workers now protesting Google's
involvement in a pentagon drone program
but Microsoft hasn't they've gone the
completely opposite direction Nadella
said if technology companies do not help
the us we're in a whole load of trouble
Microsoft has used its traditional
strengths to build a military Empire I
wanted to know how company best known
for spreadsheets and Word Documents do
it so I mapped out each of their major
military projects and the results were
fascinating Microsoft is trying to
completely change the nature of warfare
but it hasn't all gone exactly as they
planned to understand how Microsoft
became a key part of the US military's
technology strategy you have to
understand Bill Gates
today he's a laid-back philanthropist
working on problems like Global Health
but he ran Microsoft like a drill
sergeant you never understood the first
thing about this back in the 1970s
computers were really only used in Labs
or in offices that made sense they were
massive expensive machines designed to
speed up highly specific tasks the
companies that dominated the market back
then believed that no average person
would ever want their own computer Bill
Gates saw things differently well I
think we will get one in every office
and in every home build your own
computer kits we're growing in
popularity Indie hackers were starting
to use computers at home and the
technology was getting cheaper clearly
there was about to be a massive
Avalanche of technological progress the
snowball that triggered this Avalanche
was the Altair 8800 the Altair was one
of the earliest personal computers to
Modern Eyes it looks like an alien
artifact it didn't have a screen or a
keyboard you had to operate it using a
series of switches and lights on the
front panel it didn't even come fully
assembled but that didn't stop him from
buying it the Altair flew off the
shelves Bill Gates and his old buddy
from high school Paul Allen started
writing software for the Altair their
first release was a version of the basic
programming language that led Altair
users write and run their own simple
programs became for the first generation
of PCS the thing that unlocked the power
that was there bill was obsessed with
details he ran Microsoft like a general
in Wartime for Bill business was war and
competitors had to be destroyed he was
going up against an absolute giant IBM
but giants can't move fast IBM was a
decades-old bureaucracy at this point
eventually the success of the Altair
made IBM realize that they needed a
personal computer strategy the execs
knew that they couldn't make a
breakthrough product by just doing
things the old way so they created a
skunk work style r d lab in Florida the
IBM team began work on their first
personal computer they needed a software
as soon as they met Bill Gates they were
convinced that he was the best option
bill was still really young but he knew
more about soft for development than
basically anyone else at the time so the
two parties formed an alliance bill and
his team would provide IBM with an
operating system but crucially it
wouldn't be an exclusive deal we have to
be able to sell it to other outfits the
deadline to deliver was tight so instead
of trying to build everything from
scratch Bill bought an existing
operating system from a small company
named Seattle computer products
Microsoft Engineers modified that
operating system and renamed it MS-DOS
this is short for the Microsoft Disk
Operating System it was a clever move
but like a general pressing home his
Advantage Bill didn't stop there IBM
wanted to pay a fixed price for the
software license but that would have
limited Microsoft's upside and Bill knew
that so he went back and demanded a
royalty Arrangement this gave him a
guaranteed income stream and set
Microsoft up perfectly to dominate the
rapidly growing PC software Market by
1991 Microsoft was making more than 200
million dollars a year from MS-DOS Bill
had executed flawlessly but that was
just the first stage of his quest for
dominance the PC growth wave of the 80s
and 90s meant that software became a key
part of how large organizations worked
eventually one of the biggest of them
all the United States military gave Bill
Gates a call
in the mid 90s the Navy had a big debate
over what operating system should power
their warships their ultimate goal was
to develop a smart ship system that used
off-the-shelf PCS to automate tasks that
Sailors had traditionally performed
manually if it worked the Navy stood to
reduce the crew workload improve combat
Readiness and ultimately create a safer
operating environment unix-based systems
like Linux were open source stable and
flexible but the fact was that everyone
in the Navy was already using Windows at
home sensing his opportunity Bill Gates
pitched the Navy on something he called
windows for warships a bespoke version
of Windows NT 4.0 that would serve as
the standard operating system on Navy
vessels windows for warships is still
with us today and not just in the United
States either the British royal Navy
still uses a variant of Windows for
warships to provide tactical information
and torpedo controls across all of its
active submarines but upgrading the US
Navy's Fleet wasn't easy in practice in
1998 the USS Yorktown aircraft carrier
suffered a system failure that left it
dead in the water for two and a half
hours and the new Windows operating
system was squarely to blame it was the
kind of thing that was embarrassing in
peacetime but potentially fatal in
Wartime following the Yorktown debacle
it became easy to question the decision
to go with Windows critics said it was
rushed and based more on politics than
engineering requirements the source of
the problem was pretty simple too one
extra zero fed into just one application
on the network created a divide by zero
error that crashed everything it was a
big setback for the windows for warships
program but at the time Microsoft was
still riding high it was the biggest
company in the world military contracts
were just a small share of its overall
business however struggling to deliver
high quality products to the military
was just part of the problem
foreign
was like the world's worst roller
coaster Microsoft has the power today to
exercise predatory and exclusionary
control we believe that courts will
ultimately find that all the Microsoft's
actions have been completely legal and
good for consumers at its peak in 1999
Bill Gates presided over a 620 billion
dollar Company by far the biggest in the
world just two years later Microsoft had
lost 60 percent of its value and worse
still the company was floundering this
is the end of an era there are arrogant
dominance in the Computing industry
turned into uncertain anxiety part of
the problem was that the all-conquering
general had handed over control of the
company to Steve Ballmer what was once a
laser focused strategy quickly became
fragmented and this wasn't just because
of Balmer he was trying to make
Microsoft succeed when the battlefield
conditions had changed Microsoft's
original Mission was to put a computer
with Windows into every home and they
basically done it but every company
needs a second act and unfortunately for
Microsoft it took years for them to find
new Focus under balmer's leadership
Microsoft lost its core identity between
Windows Office the Xbox and various
developer tools the company went from
not really diversifying at all to
diversifying way too much none of
Microsoft's major initiatives were at
the Forefront of the next major Tech
waves the PC growth wave that turned
Microsoft into the world's biggest
company was over the 2000s were an era
dominated by consumer Internet and
mobile devices and Microsoft didn't have
a winner in either category Apple
introduced the iPod in October of 2001.
it took Microsoft five years to release
the Zune which flopped and was
discontinued in 2011. the iPhone was
launched in June of 2007. it took
Microsoft three years to release the
Windows phone which also completely
flopped Google's search engine launched
in 1997. it took Microsoft 12 years to
put out a competitive product and when
it did arrive it was Bing today Google
has 92 market share in search Bay has
just two percent all of these launches
were reactions and none of them played
to Microsoft's strength the company that
had been such a fearsome leader became a
Meek follower with the incredible and
ongoing success of Windows had left
Microsoft with one key strength
Distributing to Enterprise customers
Microsoft was still trusted by the
world's largest corporations many of
which ran on Windows and word they
needed to leverage those relationships
next time there was a major Tech Trend
in the early 2010s virtual and augmented
reality technology looked like the next
big thing so Microsoft got to work they
introduced the Xbox Connect in 2010 and
the first hololens in 2016. but
Microsoft ultimately believed that
augmented reality was too cumbersome for
everyday consumers so unlike other
headsets like the Oculus VR which were
aimed mostly at Gamers Microsoft
positioned the hololens as a
professional device for large
corporations selling to large
Enterprises would leverage Microsoft's
key strengths and Enterprises don't come
much bigger than the US military
Microsoft won a massive 22 billion
dollar contract for a project called the
integrated visual augmentation system or
ivas this will see over a hundred
thousand American soldiers equipped with
augmented reality headsets based on the
hololens technology the ivass project is
actually just the latest installment of
the military's obsession with in reality
that dates back to the 1980s the Army
had identified that technology was
transforming Battlefield intelligence
satellites and drones were generating so
much data that old Technologies just
weren't keeping up but with the right
gear that raw data could be transformed
into useful information this early
thinking became a prototype Army project
called The Soldier's computer it was far
from perfect the screen used for the
heads-up display was the same one used
in Nintendo's Virtual Boy it was low
resolution and could only display things
in red and the virtual boy was a big
flop with consumers and critics but for
some reason military officials were
determined to succeed so they doubled
down and moved the soldiers computer
project to the US Army's Natick soldier
center in Massachusetts there was no
better place for the augmented reality
attack to be put through its Paces
Project's budget was increased with more
money now on the line This looked like
the moment where this technology would
either prove its viability or be
canceled entirely by the Department of
Defense in 1992 the soldiers computer
went into field testing but first
everything was going smoothly soldiers
were really happy about how the thermal
imaging increased their sight range and
the ability to fire around corners while
staying in cover was truly novel but the
drawbacks quickly became apparent first
off the head mounted display was
extremely clunky data transfer lagged by
up to 75 seconds that is if the system
just didn't crash entirely the US Army
Research Institute published a report
which included some very honest opinions
from soldiers they called it junk they
said it sucks and they all mentioned how
painful it was to wear I don't know who
ever put it on a soldier's back it was
you know walking the street hopping a
wall going through a door or coming out
of a hatch we just wanted it to go away
we didn't want anything to do with it
the package added about 40 pounds to a
soldier's pack for comparison The Meta
Oculus Quest 2 weighs just over one
pound and honestly people don't really
like wearing the meta Oculus Quest 2
that much if people aren't going to wear
a one pound VR headset soldiers are
definitely not going to be cool with
wearing a 40 pound VR rig but despite
this an enough people high up in the
military still believed in the program
so it survived and work continued eager
to move past earlier failures the dod
rebranded the project and started
calling it Land Warrior in 1996. they
even approved a billion dollar budget
for it the dod then appointed a colonel
to act as an interface between the
engineers building the product and the
soldiers who would actually use it but
even with all of this in place the
project still had one big flaw it just
couldn't get over in order to take
advantage of the latest technology the
military had switched to using consumer
Hardware as a foundation for the Land
Warrior Project the gear didn't work in
the rain and it couldn't withstand
electromagnetic interference now this
isn't a problem for VR Gaming on your
couch but it's a huge problem when
you're a soldier in the middle of a
battlefield trying to solve these
problems blew out budgets by 1999
spending on Land Warrior had increased
by 50 percent if a private company was
burning this much cash with nothing to
show for it the project would get
scrapped investors would start asking
tough questions but too many of the
military's leaders had staked their
reputations on Land Warrior so failure
just wasn't an option now the main guy
driving this whole Vision forward was
William Owens Owens was a Navy Admiral
who served as the vice chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff during the Clinton
Administration in other words he had the
ear of the president Owens was the
biggest advocate in the armed forces for
what he called network-centric Warfare
and he actually laid out his entire
Vision in this great Charlie Rose
interview from the mid 90s I genuinely
believe in the next five years there
will be a revolution in the way this
nation fights Wars and it will come
primarily from the smart front end of
War fighting that is the ability to use
height technology surveillance of a very
large Battlefield a battlefield perhaps
the size of North Korea or Iraq
and with the ability to see that
Battlefield 24 hours a day real time all
weather we have never in the history of
War fighting ever seen the battlefield
that way that Vision was highly
compatible with the Army's new post-cold
war strategy of a smaller better
equipped fighting force by the time the
United States invaded Iraq Land Warrior
was ready to be deployed in 2005 229 U.S
infantry soldiers were fitted with Land
Warrior headsets it had been almost 20
years since the project began but it was
finally getting traction and it had just
found a use case soldiers deployed in
Iraq used their Land Warrior gear to
digitally Mark safe regrouping points
but soldiers still didn't really love it
it still needed a lot of work by June
2010 under the Obama Administration land
Warrior was rebranded again to net
Warrior the bulky pack and headgear was
gone and in its place a respect Android
phone secured to The Soldier's chest
mobile technology had become good enough
to fulfill most of William Owen's Vision
but the Army still thought it needed
more to show for all its work and money
spent so in 2019 they invited Microsoft
Engineers to a military base to teach
them about what soldiers needed from an
augmented reality headset that weekend
marked the birth of ivas you might think
given the Decades of work that had gone
into the project and Microsoft's years
of experience with augmented reality
that progress would be smooth but ivas
was plagued with problems from day one
it kind of felt like everything was back
at square one but billions of dollars
later Microsoft and the Army are
determined to make ivas work the project
has huge potential to improve soldiers
awareness and Effectiveness and besides
Russia and China are working on their
own ivas style programs so the United
States is determined not to fall behind
the current plan is to get working
hololens headsets into the field by the
end of 2023 But ultimately ibas might
not even matter because Microsoft's work
with the military goes way deeper
the consumer Internet and mobile device
Trends were both underpinned by a major
shift to the cloud when your phone or
laptop performs operations they're
usually not performing those locally
instead those calculations are being
done on a server in the cloud this time
Microsoft was determined to ride the new
wave their history with cloud computing
dates back to 2006 and an experimental
project to put Windows into the cloud
but businesses didn't want windows in
the cloud they wanted flexibility and
that's exactly what Amazon web services
AWS delivered by the time Microsoft
released the Azure cloud computing
platform in 2010 they were a long way
behind Amazon but they had one key
Advantage Distributing the products they
made to Big customers Microsoft studied
Amazon's strategy very closely and
improved Azure once they had a solid
product in place they started including
Azure credits in their Enterprise deals
this drove rapid adoption from large
customers who needed thousands of office
licenses just think about it you're a
company that's already buying lots of
Windows licenses for your employees and
all of a sudden you have a bunch of free
cloud computing credits of course you're
going to go with Microsoft Azure over
AWS which is going to cost you an arm
and a leg it wasn't long before Azure
hit a 10 billion dollar run rate and it
was growing faster than AWS Azure was
the biggest reason Microsoft's stock
price started climbing after being flat
for years Microsoft was finally riding a
major new tech wave large organizations
everywhere were closing down their data
centers and moving their hosting to the
cloud and one of those large
organizations was the US Department of
Defense years of small test projects had
left the military with over 500
different external cloud computing
contracts it was a mess that needed
tidying the military had tons of data to
sift through and centralizing it safely
and securely would allow for better
coordination between different areas of
the military this would ultimately lead
to more effective performance on the
battlefield so the dod went looking for
a cloud service provider to do this it
launched The Joint Enterprise defense
infrastructure project or Jedi Microsoft
immediately saw the opportunity Jedi
wasn't as flashy as ivas but it was
arguably more important it was an
upfront 10 billion commitment with
potentially way more further down the
road Plus winning the Jedi contract
would cement Microsoft as the military's
most trusted vendor but despite a bunch
of advantages Microsoft was still an
underdog AWS was bigger and Amazon had
just won a 600 million dollar contract
to provide cloud services for the U.S
intelligence Community the Jedi contract
looked tailor-made for AWS other Cloud
providers sensing that Amazon was the
strong favorite argued that the dod
should split up the contract so they
would at least have a chance of getting
some of the business but the whole point
of Jedi was to centralize the military's
Cloud systems dealing with multiple
vendors just didn't make sense so every
major cloud provider would have to Duke
it out during the bidding process five
companies made it to the starting line
Amazon Microsoft Google IBM and Oracle
pretty quickly though three of them
crashed out Google said they wouldn't be
working with the military on ethical
ground IBM and Oracle were eliminated
because they simply didn't have enough
capabilities so ultimately it came down
to a battle between Microsoft and Amazon
everyone thought that Amazon was going
to win everyone that is apart from
president Trump you probably remember
that one of Trump's least favorite
people was Jeff Bezos Trump didn't
really care all that much about Amazon
but Bezos was also the owner of the
Washington Post and Trump hated the
Washington Post every hour we're getting
calls from reporters on the Washington
Post asking ridiculous questions and I
will tell you this is owned as a toy by
Jeff Bezos Amazon says it's considering
its options after the pentagon's
surprise decision to award a 10 billion
dollar cloud computing contract to
Microsoft there was even a report that
Trump directly called secretary of
defense General Mattis and ordered him
to screw Amazon Amazon is making what
appears to be an unprecedented request
in his case against the government over
that 10 billion dollar Jedi contract
Amazon is seeking to depose president
Trump Secretary of Defense Mark esper
and former Defense secretary James
Mattis in that case when Microsoft won
the contract lots of people thought that
Trump tipped the scales so did Amazon
lose the Jedi contract because of Foul
Play well not necessarily because
Microsoft was a solid Choice by this
time they'd already been doing business
with the dod for decades in fact they
just signed a five-year contract worth
nearly a billion dollars to provide
Windows 10 and Associated Hardware to
the military Microsoft was making more
money from the American defense
establishment than Amazon was plus
Building Products specifically tailored
to Enterprise clients was what Microsoft
excelled at the dod was a big complex
customer but they weren't looking for
anything flashy they just wanted
something that worked ultimately Jedi
ended with a big anti-climax the
Pentagon is canceling a 10 billion
dollar deal called Jedi with Microsoft
Jedi was replaced with the joint
Warfighter Cloud capability project the
jwcc this new 9 billion dollar contract
was split between four of the five
companies that were originally part of
the Jedi bidding process Microsoft got a
piece but it wasn't the big win that
they'd hoped for
sometimes reality can be underwhelming
led by their General Bill Gates
Microsoft grew into a behemoth that
understood its allies and ruthlessly
destroyed its enemies today Microsoft's
work with the military is based on the
same principles but in the end those
setbacks don't matter all that much what
matters is that Microsoft has become one
of the US military's most trusted
vendors because it's more like the
military than any other big tech company
today the U.S military runs on Windows
XL spreadsheets and the Microsoft cloud
is it flashy not necessarily but winning
wars is a grind Microsoft knows that
better than almost anyone and as War
continues to become more digital
throughout the 21st century and the
defense department it looks for Reliable
private sector Partners Microsoft has
made itself indispensable if you'd like
to know more about how technology
affects geopolitics just watch this
video about the semiconductor war
between America and China next thanks a
lot